how to deal with the doubters and the
haters
so i got a great comment that came in
from one of my newsletter readers love
you guys
a dt who wrote in to say how do you deal
with the doubters and haters how do you
keep your self-esteem high
despite all the criticism this is a
great question to dt and
i call these people the little man you
know the people who
don't believe in your idea who just tell
you all the reasons why something's not
going to work and try to tear you down
the fact is everybody has the little man
in their life
everybody has and when you're trying to
chase your dream when you're trying to
do something big you're trying to do
something important you're trying to do
something that maybe nobody in your
family has ever done before
it's outside the norm then
at the start you're not going to have
all the answers
right it's a dream you're trying to
figure it out you're making corrections
as you go but it's not going to be
perfect you're going to make mistakes
there's going to be holes in your plan
and the little man is a person who sees
all those holes
all those things that you don't have the
knowledge of yet and tells you well
here's all the reasons why it's not
going to work out
where your real friends are the people
who will see those holes
and give you support either in a form of
a solution
here's what you can do here's a problem
you're gonna face and here's how you can
handle it
or just boosting your confidence saying
i believe in you it's gonna work out you
can do this
they don't have to agree with you okay
they don't have to necessarily think
that even what you're doing is right
but if it's your dream and you want to
see this thing through
then your real friends would be the
people who support you no matter what
now it can be hard to eliminate the
people
in your life who don't support you
because sometimes they're really close
but strategy number one is say goodbye
to the little man
now if it's somebody who's not that
close to you it's easy right to stop
talking to somebody who's
an acquaintance is easy what do you do
when it's somebody closer to you
so i want to share two examples from my
my my story
the first is there's a company i work
with it's run by two people business
partners
and one guy
is the little man and this is how i came
up with the name little man
and i showed him some of my stuff and
he's hating on it and he's
hurling insults at me and not telling me
how to make it better
and it got to the point where like this
guy the the email is going back and
this guy's just a drain he's a drain on
my life force
and i can't be around him anymore now
his business partner
i love he he does great by me he's an
awesome individual
if he was stuck in a problem he said
evan i really need your help i would
hop on a plane and fly to him to help
him out
but i have no time for his business
partner and i've eliminated him
from my life and i'm much happier and
able to do much greater things
without him being a part of what i do
another example is even more personal
there's somebody in my extended family
who
who is a little man everything she's
complaining about
is negative is is another drain on you
and doesn't support anything that you do
and became vicious and personal and
degrading
and doing things that i would you know
never imagine people doing other people
especially in your family
and so i decided to eliminate her from
my day-to-day life
and and i haven't seen her in years
and again i've been able to
you know i have much higher
self-confidence and self-esteem
because i'm not around negative people
and that may be hard for you
you know especially if they're close
family you know if it's your parents how
do you tell your parents
i'm not talking to you because you don't
support my dream and i think it's
important to try to explain how
important this is for you
that this is your life that you're
trying to do something to change the
world to make it better this is really
important to you and you really want
their support
because you can't do great things if the
people around you are just trying to
tear you down
so if you can't eliminate somebody from
your life which is the ideal scenario
then at least limit your exposure
on top of that you want to create an
environment that supports you that's
number two create
an environment that supports you you
want to create a routine
you want to be surrounded by people who
build you up you want to consume
stories and media and and information
that builds you up to give you ideas
that give you energy
it's hard enough to
follow your dreams when you have great
people around you
forget about when you have people trying
to tear you down around you but
you want to still have an environment as
much as possible that builds you up so
think about who your friends are think
about the people who you hang out with
do they help build you up
think about the books that you read the
tv shows that you watch the videos that
you consume
the newspapers or websites or whatever
it is that you read
are you surrounded by things that
build you up that give you energy that
gives you creativity
if not then change your surroundings
this is entirely
in your control you can create whatever
world you want your daily routine
what's the first thing that you do when
you wake up every day how do you spend
that first hour of your day
is it doing something that supports you
that builds you up that gives you
momentum that gives you energy
or is it something that just is just
average because again if you're just
being average
you're not going to be able to do
something great so create that
environment think about
who your friends are think about the
music you listen to the books you read
the shows you watch stop wasting time on
facebook and stupid youtube videos
and start consuming stuff that builds
you up that makes you a better
entrepreneur that gives you the
confidence to say
i can do this one of the things that
helped me the most was reading stories
of famous entrepreneurs
famous successful entrepreneurs you look
at how they got started and it was
with nothing most of them with nothing
they didn't have family background
they didn't have a angel investor
venture capitalist dumping millions into
them
they started with nothing they're often
poor broken and
ran out of money but they believed in
themselves they had people around them
who
tried to tear them down tell them why
it's not going to work out but they
believed in themselves
and reading those stories makes me feel
like
i could do the same thing right walt
disney had to go through
all of that crap in his life to become
successful
i could do the same thing you could be
the next walt disney
but you have to create that routine and
that environment that builds you up
and ignore the little man believe
for those of you watching like the video
support me by clicking on the link in
the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon